medir una superposición cuántica es tan aleatorio como lanzar una moneda, pero ¿hasta dónde podemos llevar esa
analogía antes de que se rompa? Lo descubriremos hoy en kiss in the
classroom. Bienvenido a kiss in the classroom, una serie de videos donde desglosamos un concepto fundamental que puedes
encontrar en un curso relacionado con la computación cuántica. Cada video viene acompañado de un módulo interactivo enlazado en la
descripción de abajo, así que asegúrate de verlo. Hoy hablamos de uno de los principios fundamentales en el corazón de
la teoría cuántica: la superposición. En nuestra experiencia cotidiana, los objetos siempre tienen características definidas: su ubicación, tamaño,
forma, color — todo sobre ellos está determinado y es cierto, incluso si nosotros, los observadores, aún no lo hemos medido. En el
mundo cuántico esto no es necesariamente así. Un objeto cuántico puede estar en algo llamado superposición de
múltiples estados permitidos clásicamente, que al ser medidos colapsarán aleatoriamente a uno de esos
estados. Medir un estado de superposición es como lanzar una moneda: no hay forma de saber de antemano hacia qué lado caerá.
Este indeterminismo fundamental es un aspecto incómodo de la mecánica cuántica con el que incluso Einstein tuvo problemas.
Él dijo famosamente "Dios no juega a los dados" sobre esta aleatoriedad, pero como veremos, Dios sí juega a los dados, o en
nuestro caso lanza monedas. Pero además, estas monedas están cargadas. Medir una superposición cuántica puede ser similar a
lanzar una moneda en algunos aspectos, pero la superposición en sí misma es mucho más rica y compleja que un estado
probabilístico clásico. Para ver esto, vamos a pensar en cómo funciona una moneda clásica y a contrastarla con nuestra
moneda cuántica, que exploraremos usando un qubit en un computador cuántico de IBM. Primero, una moneda clásica:
es bastante simple. Lanzas la moneda y cae cara arriba o cara abajo con un 50% de probabilidad cada una. En principio, podríamos
calcular de qué lado caerá la moneda si conociéramos las condiciones iniciales precisas de la moneda y exactamente cuánta
fuerza y torsión se aplicaron durante el lanzamiento, pero en la práctica no hay forma de saber de antemano de qué lado
caerá la moneda. Por eso usamos el lanzamiento de moneda como ejemplo canónico de un estado probabilístico clásico, donde el
resultado es esencialmente aleatorio. Si lanzara esta moneda mil veces y registrara el número de caras arriba
y caras abajo, obtendría un histograma que se vería algo así. Tenemos conteos en el eje Y
y puede ser cara arriba o cara abajo, y el
histograma mostraría que hay aproximadamente 500 conteos de cada uno, sujeto a cierta
fluctuación estadística. Podemos crear un estado similar usando un qubit en nuestro computador cuántico. Al igual que el lanzamiento de moneda, un
qubit también puede medirse en dos estados posibles: cero y uno. Si aplicamos algo llamado Hadamard gate al
qubit, lo pondrá en una superposición igual de cero y uno. Aquí hay una
visualización de ese circuit, que llamamos diagrama de circuit. Aquí el cable superior es el
qubit, y las operaciones aplicadas al qubit aparecen como cajas en los cables. El Hadamard gate se muestra con esta caja
etiquetada H, y la medición se muestra con esta caja gris etiquetada con el pequeño símbolo de medición. Envía esa
medición a un bit clásico: este cable con dos líneas. Dado que el qubit está en una superposición igual de 0 y uno, cuando
lo medimos habrá un 50% de probabilidad de que midamos cero y un 50% de que midamos
uno. Expresamos este estado de superposición cuántica como s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1, donde los cuadrados de cada uno de estos
coeficientes, también llamados amplitudes, son las probabilidades de medir cada estado. Así que, en efecto, aplicar el Hadamard
gate es el análogo a lanzar una moneda. Y al igual que lanzamos la moneda mil veces para ver las
estadísticas de que caiga cara arriba o cara abajo, podemos hacer algo similar en Qiskit con nuestra moneda cuántica.
Usaremos una primitiva de Qiskit llamada sampler, que repetirá el circuit varias veces para muestrear las estadísticas
del estado resultante. Con mil muestras del circuit anterior, tenemos algo que se ve básicamente idéntico
al histograma de la moneda clásica, sujeto a cierta fluctuación estadística. Entonces, ¿es eso todo? ¿Las superposiciones cuánticas
son esencialmente iguales a un estado probabilístico clásico, similar a lanzar una moneda? No del todo. Esto sería
un video bastante corto si ese fuera el caso. Para ver nuestra primera diferencia clave, voy a intentar algo ligeramente diferente con mi moneda clásica: en lugar
de simplemente dejarla caer sobre la mesa aterrizando cara arriba o abajo, voy a lanzar la moneda y atraparla
en el aire entre mis palmas. Ahora la moneda no está cara arriba o abajo, sino que está cara hacia la izquierda
o hacia la derecha. Entonces la lógica nos dice que esto también debería tener una probabilidad 50/50 de estar
cara a la izquierda o a la derecha. Para medir cara izquierda o derecha en nuestra moneda cuántica, podemos hacer lo que hicimos con la moneda clásica:
medir a lo largo de un eje diferente. Nuestras mediciones estándar en el computador cuántico son a lo largo del eje vertical,
igual que la medición habitual de cara arriba o abajo de la moneda clásica. Pero también podemos preguntarle a nuestra moneda cuántica si está
cara izquierda o derecha. Llamamos a estos dos estados a lo largo del eje X: más o menos.
Para esto usamos la primitiva de Qiskit llamada estimator. Para complicar un poco las cosas, en lugar de devolver un histograma como
hace el sampler, el estimator nos dará el llamado valor de expectación de cualquier observable del qubit. Para
entender este valor de expectación, imagina que ganas un dólar cada vez que la moneda cae cara arriba y pierdes un dólar cuando
cae cara abajo. El valor de expectación es cuánto dinero puedes esperar ganar en promedio con cada lanzamiento. Dado que
es igualmente probable que ganes o pierdas un dólar, el valor de expectación sería cero. El mismo razonamiento se puede aplicar
al qubit. Cuando encontramos el valor de expectación de X, al aplicar X al estado más obtenemos
el valor +1, y al estado menos obtenemos menos uno. Así que si tuviéramos una
distribución 50/50, obtendríamos un valor de expectación de cero. Pero no es así: obtenemos un valor de expectación de más uno,
lo que significa que la moneda siempre se mide como más a lo largo del eje X. Eso sería como lanzar una
moneda, atraparla y garantizar que la cara siempre apuntara hacia la derecha. Esto se debe a que una
superposición no es solo una distribución de probabilidad. Recuerda cómo expresamos un estado cuántico:
s es igual a C0 por el estado 0 más C1
por el estado 1, donde cada uno de estos coeficientes es complejo, lo que significa que
tienen partes reales e imaginarias. Así que nos hablan de las probabilidades, pero también ocultan otra cantidad llamada
la fase. Cierto coeficiente C puede escribirse así,
donde C es igual a la magnitud multiplicada por esta fase, donde este fi es la
fase. Es un poco como la fase de una onda, o la ubicación de las crestas y valles de una onda. Si dos ondas están en fase
entre sí, de modo que sus crestas y valles se alinean, entonces se combinarán para formar una onda el doble de
alta. A esto lo llamamos interferencia constructiva. Si están desfasadas, como
aquí, entonces interfieren destructivamente, cancelándose completamente entre sí. Para ver cómo la fase puede causar
interferencia en nuestra moneda cuántica, intentemos aplicar el Hadamard dos veces en lugar de solo una. Ahora bien, clásicamente
esto no tendría ningún sentido: si aplicar el Hadamard equivale a lanzar una moneda al aire, no puedes lanzar una moneda que ya está girando. Pero veamos qué
pasa desde el punto de vista cuántico. Aplicamos el Hadamard dos veces y medimos el estado resultante.
Sorprendentemente, ya no tenemos una probabilidad del 50/50. El histograma resultante muestra que en todos los casos medimos el
qubit en el estado cero. Así que el segundo Hadamard ha devuelto el qubit al estado cero del que partimos. Es
un poco difícil de ver al principio, pero esto se debe a la interferencia del estado cuántico. En lugar de
interferir en el espacio real como una onda física, la interferencia ocurre en el espacio de información abstracto del qubit.
El segundo gate Hadamard hizo que la parte cero de la superposición interfiriera constructivamente, mientras que la parte uno de la
superposición interfirió destructivamente y desapareció. Exploremos más: podemos cambiar la fase usando
algo llamado phase gate. Así que ahora apliquemos un Hadamard para crear la superposición, apliquemos un desfase de
pi radianes y luego apliquemos el segundo Hadamard. Ahora parece que nuestra moneda cuántica siempre sale en el estado uno.
El desfase de pi intercambió las partes del estado de superposición que estaban en fase y fuera de fase entre sí.
Así que el estado final es uno en lugar de cero. Sería como lanzar una moneda al aire y, mientras está en el aire, poder
aplicar una operación que garantice que siempre caiga cara arriba o siempre cara abajo, dependiendo de la
operación. Imposible en el caso clásico, pero no en el cuántico. Lo que hemos aprendido de estos experimentos es
que esta nueva capacidad de la moneda cuántica se debe a su fase: una cualidad que tiene una superposición cuántica pero que una
distribución de probabilidad clásica no tiene. Así que el lanzamiento de moneda clásico en realidad no es una analogía tan buena para una
superposición, porque no dice nada sobre esta fase. Creo que podemos hacerlo mejor. Voy a hacer otro
experimento con nuestra moneda. Tengo la moneda sobre la mesa con cara arriba. Para ponerla cara abajo, simplemente la doy vuelta. Esto
es el equivalente computacional de un gate NOT. Digamos que queremos construir una operación que, aplicada dos veces, sea
equivalente a este gate NOT. Podemos llamar a esta operación raíz cuadrada de NOT. Piensa en lo que estamos haciendo físicamente
cuando aplicamos el gate NOT: la estamos rotando 180° alrededor del eje X, por ejemplo. Así que si rotáramos la moneda
solo 90° alrededor del eje X, obtendríamos la raíz cuadrada de NOT. Entonces hemos aplicado
nuestra raíz cuadrada de NOT y la moneda está parada sobre su canto. Ahora podemos preguntarnos: ¿está cara arriba o cara abajo? Pues
claramente ninguna de las dos. Pero podríamos agregar un paso al proceso de medición para obligarla a estar cara arriba o cara abajo. Ahora la
moneda caerá hacia uno u otro lado con igual probabilidad. En principio podríamos predecir
hacia dónde caerá, pero en la práctica es suficientemente difícil de predecir como para que sea esencialmente aleatorio. Si quiero
medir si está cara izquierda o cara derecha, puedo aplanarla en esa dirección de forma similar y nos dará de nuevo una probabilidad
del 50/50 entre izquierda y derecha. Pero en esta dimensión, cara al frente o cara atrás,
la cara ya mira hacia adelante, así que el 100% de las veces mediremos cara al frente. Así que mientras las mediciones en X y Z
arrojan resultados aleatorios, la medición en Y siempre dará el mismo resultado. Si recordamos el
experimento del lanzamiento de la moneda cuántica de la sección anterior, esto recuerda a cómo se comportaba la moneda cuántica tras
aplicar el Hadamard: el qubit se medía como cero o uno con probabilidad 50/50 en la dirección Z, pero
siempre en el estado plus y nunca en el estado minus a lo largo de X. Esto sugiere que quizás una moneda parada sobre su
canto es una mejor forma de visualizar un estado de superposición de un qubit que una moneda girando locamente en el aire.
Apliquemos un gate raíz cuadrada de NOT en nuestra moneda cuántica. En Qiskit tenemos este sencillo
circuit. Luego usaremos el estimator para verificar el valor esperado de los tres observables X, Y y Z, que son algo así como
colapsar nuestra moneda a lo largo de cada una de las tres dimensiones, como acabo de mostrar. Así que los valores esperados son 0,
menos uno y 0 para X, Y y Z respectivamente. Este es el mismo resultado que
obtuvimos para la rotación raíz cuadrada de NOT aplicada a la moneda clásica. De hecho, hay una analogía precisa entre la
moneda y el estado del qubit. Ahora podemos visualizar el estado del qubit como un vector que apunta en la dirección de la cara
de la moneda, perpendicular a su superficie. Así que cara arriba, o el estado cero,
en la moneda cuántica equivale a un vector apuntando recto hacia arriba. Cara abajo, o uno, apunta recto hacia abajo. Y cualquier
superposición igual de 0 y uno apunta horizontalmente. La fase del estado cuántico determina la dirección horizontal exacta
a la que apunta: por ejemplo, si apunta a lo largo del eje X, a lo largo del eje Y o en algún punto
intermedio. Este vector se conoce como el vector de Bloch y determina de forma completa y única el estado cuántico de un solo
qubit. Ahora podemos reimaginar cada gate que hemos visto en este video como una rotación o una serie de rotaciones en la
moneda, o equivalentemente en el vector de Bloch. El gate NOT es una rotación de
180° alrededor del eje X. Cuando se aplica a nuestro estado cero, o cara arriba, voltea al
estado abajo, o uno. La raíz cuadrada de NOT es solo 90° alrededor de ese mismo eje X. Partiendo
del estado cara arriba, esto lo rota a cara al frente. Un phase gate es una rotación de phi alrededor del eje Z. Como
cara arriba está alineada con el eje Z, esto no hace nada a la moneda. El gate Hadamard es un poco más complicado:
al principio lo comparamos con lanzar una moneda, haciendo que girara sin control en el aire. Pero el Hadamard es en realidad una
rotación controlada y determinista de la moneda, como todos los demás gates. El Hadamard se realiza rotando 90°
alrededor del eje Y y luego 180° alrededor del eje X. Así que aplicado al estado cara arriba,
termina siendo cara a la derecha. Así que no hay nada aleatorio en un estado de superposición cuántica ni en ninguna de
las operaciones estándar que realizamos en el qubit. Cada operación es determinista y reversible. La única
vez que la aleatoriedad entra en juego es cuando decidimos medir el estado cuántico. Si un estado cuántico está siquiera en una
superposición es realmente una cuestión de perspectiva. Como ya habrás notado, somos libres de elegir nuestro
sistema de coordenadas: X, Y y Z pueden apuntar en cualquiera de tres direcciones ortogonales. Así que
si tenemos una superposición de 0 y uno en un sistema de coordenadas, podemos definir un nuevo sistema de coordenadas, o una nueva
base, en la que el estado apunte puramente en la dirección Z+ y por lo tanto no esté en un estado de superposición.
Así que cuando decimos que un qubit está en superposición, también debemos definir nuestro sistema de coordenadas o
base. Puede que termines este módulo con la impresión de que acabamos de eliminar todo el misterio de la mecánica cuántica.
Al fin y al cabo, uno de los aspectos supuestamente más extraños —el estado de superposición de un qubit— es en realidad tan simple como un
vector tridimensional. Pero ten en cuenta que la moneda sigue siendo solo una analogía, y que incluso el vector de Bloch es
solo una herramienta de visualización. Para calcular las probabilidades de los resultados de la medición, no podemos decir qué está
haciendo realmente un estado cuántico antes de medirlo, porque comprobarlo requiere una medición. Discutiremos este
dilema de cuál es la verdadera naturaleza de un estado cuántico y cómo el fenómeno cuántico del entrelazamiento puede ayudarnos
a elucidarlo en otro episodio de Qiskit en el aula, dedicado todo a la desigualdad de Bell. Mientras tanto, si
quieres jugar con monedas cuánticas para aprender por ti mismo sobre los estados de superposición de un qubit y cómo controlarlos,
visita el módulo de monedas cuánticas enlazado en la descripción. Gracias por ver y ¡hasta la próxima!